how are you guys doing today
crazy
we're happy to get this movie out from
in front of people's eyes
um i am definitely curious no one who
will be watching this
interview will have seen the movie yet
so eamon do you mind actually starting
with like
talk what is the film about for people
that aren't familiar
i'm asking for it's about a gang of
vigilante
femmes who travel across uh uh travel
across the south exacting revenge in
places where the system has
[ __ ] over people in uh various
different marginalized communities
and that's it
i definitely think it's a little bit
more than that um one other thing
listen i have a lot i want to ask about
but uh but i'm curious
uh what what was it about um the script
and the project
uh that got you involved i'm
specifically talking about
where vanessa and alexander
um i mean i'm all about seeing strong
women we need more
strong women in films and this is
a group of the ultimate badasses who are
leaning into these things that may seem
controversial and like really pushing
the boundaries and seeing
where that line is between
uncomfortability and comfortability and
i feel like the entire time we're just
leaning into these topics
not blazing over them and i think it's
really important
and it's really magical to see what
comes out of that
yeah i think one of my favorite things
about this movie is the fact that
it is female leading you know i think a
lot of the time with these types of
movies you see
the women getting saved by a man and in
this
situation women are saving each other
girls for girls man and i think that
that's something that we all need
uh to see especially in film uh eamon
something that really impressed me about
the film
was your editing technique um i really
it's very uh it's not following the
conventional narrative like the way that
most movies are edited
it's very exciting you have mick you you
have uh photographs mixed into footage
and um can you sort of talk about i can
only imagine how long this edit took
so can you sort of talk about the
editing of this movie because
to me it might have taken 10 years and
yeah i mean
it wasn't that far off um uh yeah well
you know we shot this movie right before
cove it happened
and there were a number of obstacles
that came into play
um in you know having to do with that
and
there were certain obstacles that we hit
because we couldn't go reshoot things we
couldn't
get some of the things that we planned
to kind of go back to oklahoma and pick
some certain stuff up
so we had to try to figure out how do we
make this thing that is currently a
problem
not just how do we solve that but how do
we you know try to make that something
that's going to bring
another new element to the movie
something that will
you know we'll bring you know exciting
elements that that weren't there for
and so there was a lot of that a lot of
the problem solving uh
is stuff that i feel like actually
really made the movie
um even more interesting and you know
and brought some of those
those less traditional elements um also
uh
uh uh i've always loved you know kind of
like exploitation movies and stuff like
that with some
uh with elements and stuff like that and
um
one of the things i would say is a goal
with this movie was to try to take some
take the exploitation out of an
exploitation movie so you know
i hope that uh that that's where we
landed to a certain extent
i can only imagine for for the actors in
something like this i can only imagine
what it's like watching it for the first
time because
on set you can't see what the vision
actually is going to be
with especially this editing technique
uh can you sort of talk about the two of
you have you seen the finished film
i haven't seen the latest cut yeah i
hear this almost it's most okay
95 okay we saw 95 yeah
it's that extra 5 that i think is going
to be really exciting to see
i'm excited for you guys well can you
can you sort of talk about those seeing
it for the first time and how it
compared
to what you maybe thought going in
versus you know the finished film
the pictures definitely add a whole
other element we have an amazing
photographer on set with us the entire
time just snapping away
certain moments you'd take us and be
like stand over here and we'd get some
shots and
i think that like the energy and the
tone that we kind of set
on in our workspace was very much
the essence of the film like we were a
bunch of strong empowered women
who were vibing off of each other and
working off of each other and like
bringing our own things to the table
that it really felt extremely
collaborative and i feel like the soul
of what we did
is in the movie yeah definitely and i
think that there were moments in which
we were like oh
wouldn't it be really cool if and so
when you sit in the edit and you see it
like come to life on screen you're just
kind of like
oh that worked oh that was actually way
cooler than we thought it was
yeah you know like took it to the next
level how hard was it for all three of
you to not spend
all day when david patrick kelly was on
set
just geeking out about the warriors and
other films like that
i was very very excited i didn't realize
that that was
who was going to play that role until he
stepped on set
honestly um and yeah i really like that
and he's
like such a cool guy he's like he's an
older guy now but he was like
we're in 20 degree weather in the middle
of an oil field like 75 mile an hour
winds and he's just doing like fingertip
push-ups
in between takes and like just like
teaching people how to play the fiddle
it was
you can't wrap your head around or i i
couldn't he was so cool
and like kind of being able to do stunts
and wrestle him to the ground and
be a little rough with him after they
called cut i'd be like hey you know i'd
reach to kind of give him a hand and he
would be like i got it
you just spring right back up and i was
like oh my goodness this guy is still a
gangster
i want to see you when i grow up yeah
seriously
i would have pulled the chris farley on
set and just you know been like remember
that time but anyway vanessa you have a
very interesting look in this film
and i'm curious if you ever took it out
to like a coffee shop
and enjoyed being unrecognizable we
we rocked our looks all throughout town
because it was a very tiny town that we
filmed in
so when we were waiting what would
normally be on set after hair and makeup
and in wardrobe there was a bar across
the street and we knew everyone who
worked there and there'd be karaoke
nights so we would do karaoke
while waiting to go on set in our full
wardrobe and hair makeup
and have the most funded time but it
also was a tiny tiny town like
people didn't bother us they loved
having us and the town actually like
wrote an article in their newspaper
about how we were not the standard
hollywood types
and we were just so happy that we left a
really good impression with them
yeah it was so much fun being in our
costume and wardrobe and there were
moments where
v and i would like do karaoke as our
characters
yeah and like act as our characters and
it was
it was a lot of fun i think it just dove
us deeper into
our our characters and like some really
cool ways but like my
favorite memory of like walking through
town i think is when i first met
alex and we were like let's go get some
food there's like one spot in town
and they went last night so but we were
walking and it's my
first time being alex and she's just got
this little switchblade
it's a little practice switchblade but
she's just walking through the streets
like
swinging around her switchblade and i
was like damn this [ __ ] is badass
it was cool we had to like keep telling
people like oh it's it's dulled like
i'm not really out there trying to fight
people
but i wanted to be good at all the
tricks because my character was
you know so i would just just be
flipping it around people be like oh my
god
i'm really good at that thank you thank
you that was actually something i was
going to address that it
looked like you had been practicing oh
yeah she had
oh right all day all day every day i'm
flipping the switchblade around
because my character knew exactly what
she was doing and her weapon of choice
was a switchblade so for me
i was like you better know this
butterfly knife like the back of your
hand
i am curious listen you guys you have a
great cast
and but you are obviously making this on
a
tight schedule and a tight budget
because it's an indie movie
can you talk a little bit about the
challenges of trying to get everything
that you wanted to get
with the time and money that you had
um yeah uh it was very very tricky
um and there but it was again it was one
of
uh one of those instances where the
obstacles
are only options to take them in stride
and figure out
a way to try to turn that around into
something that would be really great and
like a location isn't the way that you
know we can't find a certain kind of
location so how do we adjust
this part of the movie and and all the
places where we did that where we were
like
this is initially a problem so you know
um all that stuff ended up being great
also it was very very helpful especially
as a first-time director but
um like having these guys having people
having here see having people who have
been you know like not just have been
through it before but like
champions among mere mortals like we
you know the amount of the amount of
health and generosity and support
that these guys guys gave is like i am
endlessly thankful and grateful
and we i never ever would have been able
to do this um i learned so much from
you guys it means a lot to me all the
help and it really
that was how we got it done it was the
you know everybody
pitching in and people yeah going above
and beyond it was
i'm very thankful i think that ezra is
very charismatic
in all of his movies but especially this
one and you have an interesting
aesthetic at the beginning of the film
with ezra almost existing in like a
youtube-esque
world with like social media and then
you transition to almost like a movie
point of view when you're with uh piercy
so can you sort of talk about the
aesthetic choice
of doing that especially at the
beginning and also putting ezra
front and center as the leader of this
alt-right movement
um yeah there are two things i would say
one is that
that was definitely another one of those
instances in which like
we're not going to be able to shoot
certain things we're not going to be
able to do certain things
how do we simplify what we're trying to
do and
um and make it all work
um and so doing kind of you know lo-fi
youtube stuff we don't have to assemble
full crew and stuff like that that was
very helpful and a lot of that stuff was
shot after our principal photography um
and then originally i didn't i the plan
was to not introduce that character or
any of those elements of the movie until
much later i really did want
um uh i wanted the story to be
focused on on on the female characters
and really for us to see get to know
them and build that world
and i had the everyone who watched it
was having the same exact problem which
was just like i have no idea
who the bad guys are who were fighting
so that was something that we were
trying to address and that was sort of
how that
you know and we were starting to use the
photos and stuff so that was that was
just when those
elements play yeah the magic of ed
it's amazing what you can learn you know
from uh test screens and stuff like that
or from friends and family screenings um
can you guys sort of talk about uh one
of the things that i really
enjoyed about this movie also is it's
told from the point of view
of a you know female of color it's not
just a bunch of white people
encountering
or trying to solve this there was an
earlier iteration of the movie i was
already pretty overwhelmed of
like like trying to take on really
including
telling a story from a number of
perspectives that are very different
from my
personal one and there was an earlier
iteration of this script
where i was so um nervous
about that that i i didn't want to take
on also the challenge of like well now i
also i'm gonna try to speak for
not just women not just people who have
personally
experienced sexual trauma um but um
but also people of color and that was
and it was like it was really it was a
mainly
a much more white-centered story and
but as i was doing the research to try
to write that movie it became so
apparent so quickly that if i was doing
that i would be doing
uh i would let my like fear uh create a
drastic disservice to
um you know to trying to tell this story
authentically and genuinely
you know and um and the you know the
statistics even of just like
of of the you know the fact that women
of color
are you know so much so heavily um
[Music]
you know kind of the statistics of uh
of how women of color are affected by
sexual violence
it became immediately very clear that if
i
didn't address that and didn't take that
into account i would be do
you know there was no point to do any of
this and that in fact i would be
you know kind of doing everyone a
disservice um
and so when i went back to the drawing
board and it was very difficult but
again
you know i got a lot of help from from
people who
who and not just these guys but also
throughout the whole writing process you
know really trying to talk to a lot of
different people with different
relationships to
race and gender and violence and
sexuality and stuff like that and
just really try to make sure that
whatever's going on
ultimately on screen is genuine is you
know authentic or not
i thought you did a great job with that
uh vanessa and alexandra can you sort of
talk about how you got ready for this
role
and if you felt any sort of added
responsibility playing these kinds of
characters
well to kind of go back to your previous
uh question with eamonn
i think that it's really important for
white filmmakers to
put women and women of color in the
forefront of their films especially in
today's day and age
i think that that sets the bar and
further pushes the narrative that our
lives matter
and that our stories are important
and specific and i think that that is
where
tv and film is headed and so i applaud
eamon and our producers for making sure
that
that narrative is continued throughout
um
when it comes to preparing for these
roles
like i said i was constantly using my
switchblade i was constantly
trying to come up with different uh
means of being these characters
and i was lucky enough to have
fellow actors that cared as much about
their
character development as as i did and
we're coming up with walks and we're
coming up with handshakes and we're
coming up
with all of the different nitty-gritty
things that i think
make these characters so special and
individual
to our own specific choices and
that's kind of what moves that needle
forward when it comes to
uh character building is taking note of
every little thing and making a specific
choice and running with it
i think a big thing for me was my
wardrobe i feel like as soon as i put my
fit on i was like here she is
um the way i walked was different the
way and then the makeup
and like i we created like a whole thing
with all these little tattoos all over
and
and i would just look in the mirror and
i wouldn't see me i would see this new
person
and i would look at this group of women
that i just adore and respect and love
and see what they're bringing to the
table and i feel like
it was just a very energy flowing
safe space i actually have an individual
question for each of you guys if you
don't mind
uh for eamon i believe you are a star
wars fan
or am i mistaken no you're much so
so i'm definitely curious for you if you
don't mind can you please share
your top three star wars films and your
thoughts on
episode nine original trilogy that's it
everything outside of that is
you know it's us i mean i kind of like
kind of like seven
but yeah i mean in no particular order
probably empire for empire strikes back
and then
uh new hope and return the jedi but
those are the only three that we're
really talking about i go back and forth
between empire or star wars being the
best one depending on the day
i am incredibly excited for lin's
directorial debut tick tick boom
you are both a part of it and i would
really love to hear
what it was like being part of that
project and working with lynn
on his directorial day we started right
before
copen we were in rehearsals
every day dancing singing just being
put through the whole musical theater
works which
i personally well we both love it we
love it we live for that that's like
playtime
um and then we started principal
photography and
i think got only a couple days in and
had to shut down the entire thing
and then we picked it back up in
september
and we had to go back into rehearsals
because it had been
months um and picked it up from there
but it was it was challenging because of
kovit
it was the first production we had done
since the lockdown
um rules were uh
very restrictive for cast and crew for
everyone involved
um but you know kind of made everyone
have to go the extra mile
in order to be there um but lynn being
the shining light that he is brought
such an energy of joy and playfulness
and just excitement um because he loves
jonathan larson and he loves tick tick
boom and he's been dreaming about this
for as long as he can remember so the
fact that he got to do it
it just that radiates that's a whole
other energy
and for us to be there with him we all
have our own connections i think with
jonathan larson and
it just felt like there were moments of
magic
um and he is a big reason why that was
yeah it was so much fun working with
lynn and
the second with vanessa said it was like
this child-like energy of of excitement
and everyone was really happy to be
there and also it was a
bunch of musical theater nerds so it was
like
we do this thing and it was really cool
that lin did this thing where like we
like to sing whatever we're doing
so it's like sitting at a table and then
we create like an entire song to it but
it was covent
so we weren't necessarily allowed to
sing on set unless we were filming
and there were there were coveted
officers who would come over and like
tell us hey you gotta walk this way or
don't forget your mask
and we're like all getting ready and
like walking on the set
and lynn's like what get out of the set
and then a covert officer would come and
be like excuse me mr miranda oh you're
not allowed to sing on set and i felt so
bad for that guy because i was like
dang you gotta tell lin manuel miranda
that has to be the hardest sad because i
feel like
because we were a bunch of theater nerds
like if we
could have been filming not during covid
oh my gosh the stuff that would have
been happening in between tapes and
setups like then we couldn't explore
that because
we weren't allowed to sing unless the
cameras were rolling
um but you know we made the best of it
and we're so
proud excited because it's a really
special film yeah just like this
yeah listen
listen congrats on this film
specifically i hope it's a huge
premiere and that uh gets you know sold
the whole thing um and obviously i can't
wait for tic tic boom as well
um good have a fantastic time in new
york